like Matt Ryan had a great day yesterday
the Falcons had a great day yesterday is
they beat the Saints in New Orleans and
Matt joining us now prior to yesterday's
win you guys had one win so what's it
like celebrating when you're two and
seven as opposed to seven and two well
so good
it had been too long in between the two
of them that's for sure
but it is different you know when you're
struggling and it's been a rough go for
the last you know five or six weeks it
feels good to get that done particularly
when you're on the road and you know you
got the fight back and everybody's
together you know it was fun last night
and much needed for us if knowing what
you know now and I could take you back
to August 30th and you could change
something back then like before the
season starts what would you do
differently you know I'm not sure I'm
not sure you can put your finger on it
of what the one thing would be that that
would kind of change the direction for
us I think if anything it would just be
a reminder to everybody of how fine the
line is between wins and losses in this
league and and and you know that
everything you do is important and
everything makes a difference and that
would be you know the reminder that I
would give everybody because we've got a
handful of losses that you know we're
one score games and you know it's two or
three of those go differently we're
right in the mix right now we're kind of
in the middle of the pack and and we're
not an important where our backs are
against the wall so that would that
would kind of be the message easier to
like move forward after a loss when
you're 34 or when you're 24 you know 24
I think you know there's there's just so
much he's just naive you know you don't
realize you know how hard it is and how
tough it is and all of those things and
I think you just you just kind of move
on a little bit easier at 34 you've got
a little bit more scar tissue and they
sting a little bit more Julio Jones
Calvin Ridley of
I went to Alabama to give them a little
grief on Sunday morning after the loss
to LSU well we were we were all in the
hotel watching that game and one of our
other wide receivers Russell gage went
to LSU so the back and forth between the
three of them was was pretty good and
russ was was flying high man first time
they had one I guess of nine years or
something like that so he was feeling
pretty good nobody brings up Boston
College though right
Devonta Freeman did because he went to
Florida State and he brought up the fact
that we lost to them and a little bit of
money needed to change hands it was
close though I mean you guys almost had
a chance now you got Notre Dame coming
up next don't you yeah they've got
another dame coming up and you know
stuff that was one that you know they
made it to knock off and just didn't go
their way on Saturday afternoon which
was tough to see it was I think after
the week to win against Philadelphia and
I ask you something simple could you
work the named McLovin into one year
audible calls and he and we listened did
we miss it it was loud yesterday it was
loud in that dome I'm not sure I'm not
sure you could pick up all the calls
wait are you saying you said I'm going
to take your word for it Matt because I
did not say yesterday I can't lie I
can't tell a lie but I still got seven
games regular season to work this and
keep listening ok that might be the
reason you're 2 and 7 you know have you
had a strange audible call like Payton
got credit for Omaha Omaha and I think
Roethlisberger didn't he do the the Bud
Light did he do that one do you have a
c5 you know we would be a game we hit
against right after I talked to you guys
against Philadelphia the play we hit was
called Stella and so I'm still waiting
for a couple cases as you tell us to
arrival to tour that would be a nice
little marketing deal to get done okay
but who comes up with those names
ah man it's across the board
sometimes it's the coaches sometimes
it's players just changing you know as
we its whatever triggers you know
whatever triggers guys to remember
things and so sometimes a case of beer
or a beer call is a good thing for the
offensive line for them to remember you
know plays by now I know your kids are
young but when you go home tonight
and there's a big game on nationally
with Seattle against the 49ers do you
care about that game yeah I watch you
know I'm a fan I really am you know a
fan of the NFL and enjoy watching enjoy
watching other teams and what does your
wife go come on on can please into it
you know my wife is she is into the
sports and and and loves it and so
typically our Monday nights if we're not
playing is the date night and so you
know put the kids to bed and head out to
dinner and find a find a spot that has
the game on and you know we like you
know our deal we kind of like to sit at
the bar have dinner at the bar with a
game on in the background nice oh yeah
that's yeah well then you knew that
going into the marriage then they it was
that part of the vows in it you got to
do your research beforehand this is a go
it's a good thing hey congrats on the
win yesterday it's one of those games
while I'm watching I'm going wait which
one's the the team that could go to the
Super Bowl this year like it was did you
at some point go oh look at what we're
doing to the Saints here in New Orleans
yeah for sure there's there's definitely
a feeling of you know disappointment
with how the first half of the season is
gone and what we feel like we're capable
of doing because I thought yesterday we
didn't do anything extraordinary we just
did what we're capable of doing and
played well played smart played
efficiently and be a good football team
on the road well Congrats
and we appreciate your time and of
course we'll be listening and the game
against Carolina when you yell out it is
coming it is coming
I put a note in there I'm telling you
it's coming thank you man good to talk
to you
all right thanks dad I'm gonna have to
hold him to then now I gotta listen
close now I gotta watch Falcon games
that's gonna be tough
four more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]